think you and i should do a rv trip you
and i
i'd love to go to canada bring the dogs
though
oh goby doesn't like long road trips
babe you know that but julio and remy do
um are we gonna keep this house as an
animal farm
or yeah we there's new family members
here i mean i [ __ ] i'll just be
honest with you when did you find out
oh my god i'd land oh you land
i land in lax i'm like oh
finally home i'm going to go home relax
you know and all of a sudden i get a
text
all right i look at it it's like there
was an emergency at the hospital or i
don't know what the [ __ ] thing was i
didn't say hospital oh you said there
was an emergency yeah
i'll read it to you i'll read it to you
it's right here this is what i
might have exaggerated it a bit i don't
care that might have been a strategic
mood to do it last minute
very good move so here you are there you
go so
um you say babe
there were two dogs in an emergency
situation so i'm taking care of them
downstairs for a couple days only
a couple days only are they still here
it's only been a couple days
yeah when are they leaving let me tell
you something okay
don't get defensive don't get defensive
i'm not here for a fight
i'm just asking you a question when are
they leaving
whenever they get adopted
okay listen
you try to die listen i know here we go
listen and it was an emergent situation
because
it was um a homeless couple from skid
row
who um got ill and they could no longer
care for their dogs
um that that's to me is the most
emergent situation
but i've always wanted to do more i've
always wanted to
help in any way i can um and this is
just one way i feel like i can do that
and yeah those two dogs are with me now
also they're [ __ ] perfect by the way
you just met mamoa the big one the big
so sweet he's the sweetest guy and the
tiny little
black chihuahua her name is lisa bonet
she's like one of those birds that sits
on top of like hippos in the
in by the river all right they just
perch there you don't even know she's
there she's so low maintenance these
dogs
homeless dogs are are the best dogs by
the way they're also best of friends and
so
um but the pit bull is the biggest
pitbull i've ever seen so big he's a big
boy
right first the biggest head i've ever
seen i mean i the only thing
creature that i've seen with a bigger
head is marianne
okay that's your friend that's your
friend from denver god bless you
marianne
you guys are friends now stuff i love
her i know about her she has a very big
head for her body and that's it that's
the fact you guys have very similar
proportions i don't know what you're
talking about
all right why do i don't know why every
time i attack aunt marianna you have to
attack me back
well it's because it's like for someone
who who has your like
bodily proportions i'm just surprised
how much cute
as [ __ ] and they're scientific well you
also look like a chicken drumstick but
okay i i don't know why it became that
roast
all right but why are you doing that
he's not a dais bro but let me just go
back to the dogs right so
the dog is the biggest and then uh lisa
bonay
is the size of the paw of
this dog yeah with their best of friends
right and you're right
that the dog seems like one of those
like um you know there are certain
birds that will hop on other birds right
to get the food
yeah like you know big what's a big
ostrich like an ostrich
yeah we'll go and a little bird will sit
on top of
ostrich soldiers um shoulders because
when the ostrich
walks it brings up mosquitoes and bugs
from the ground
yeah and the other you know i mean
little tiny bird will grab
the food yeah so it's almost as if like
like they're
they're symbiotic in that way that's
exactly the word that's the correct
scientific term
i'm so surprised why it's symbiosis yeah
i'm not dumb
but anyway so are we gonna say we're
gonna
if you guys are interested in adopting
jason momoa and lisa bonay
please go over to loveliorescues
instagram and you can
um fill out an application there they
are just the sweetest
easiest house guests we've had yeah
so that's it we're animal farm is that
so horrible
yeah what's what's going on what text
are you reading
uh [ __ ] thick head
shot i'm so i'm so i'm so curious is it
juicy
just give us a little is it juicy or
will you cut it out
just keep it light yeah keep it looking
i can't keep it out it's either we cut
it out or not
they look
don't go through there go another way go
over there
no wrong way come here baby come here
give people your mask oh hi baby bye
baby
what's uh that's uh that's lisa bonnet
over there she's very shy
but she's really sweet she just don't be
okay
we're potty trained in this house
they're like literally she's really
always staying close to him
oh don't go through there cause does the
camera get him george
yep
little one seems very timid yes
wow how do people find out about the
dogs where you can
apply lovely rescue there you guys go on
instagram
i cannot rave about them enough they are
such
sweet little angels so sweet
uh would you guys like an unhelpful
advice question yes please
yeah go ahead on hopeful advice with
bobby and kalyla
hey tiger belly my name is chris i am a
24 year old law student and i live with
my girlfriend and her family in their
house
when i was noted notified that school
would be all over zoom i decided to live
here so i could save money and not have
to pay for an apartment closer to campus
the problem is my girlfriend developed a
gluten intolerance over the past few
months and she constantly burps